so leute bevor es losgeht mit dieser
runde sowie games noch eine kurze
anmerkung von meiner seite ich habe
leider gerade ein paar probleme mit
premiere und kann deswegen keine
facetime bringen aber ich arbeite daran
und ich denke in den nächsten tagen wird
es wieder videos mit fans gegeben und
jetzt würde ich sagen viel spaß mit dem
video
jo leute an alle sg seien herzlich
willkommen wir sind heute in den
survival games auf dem hd und mit dabei
ist der trainer dennis menn ist und
nichts bekommen irgendwie scheiße zum
einfach nur holz axt das nicht so
wir haben noch etwas bekommt alter sind
krass viele kisten mit ihm kann ich gib
dem google den bogen kann ich gebrauchen
die fakten
ob ich ein typ mit dem bogen kehlen kann
aber auch mal von den handel
alter geil und alter des knapp kranke
scheiße scheiße das ist einfach so also
du meine hinterhergelaufen und der war
halt im wasser ihr alter mache ich keine
fehler mache jetzt bloß keine fehler
der war einfach hinter mir im wasser und
ich arbeite mit dem bogen auf ihn drauf
gebaut ist keine ahnung gibt die
forscher gekillt irgendwie hätte
wahrscheinlich nicht volle leben ich
habe glaube ich drei vier starts gegeben
aber dauern
jetzt habe ich einfach ein eisen schwert
eine goldene jazz plate ihren leggins
und läufer musste aber trotzdem erstmal
rumlaufen
das war auch wieder scheiß knapp leute
geht doch mal der chat wieder behinderte
chat walter was es für eine knappe
stunde sollte
immerhin mal
einfach überall die geier lange diese
sind krass alte könnten irgendwo
hingehen
maciel erstmal reagan und erstmal lively
gossip richtig viel pfeile bekommen geil
neu für mich das geile ist ein gong
adidas man wirklich endlos viel nahrung
hat das ist perfekt nicht nur
pfeifenmann so sich sorgen machen muss
hier so ganz afrikas teil aber dass man
halt verhungern muss das problem nicht
richtig gut alter den hätte ich richtig
gut da bitte ich von den typen ganz am
anfang abgezogen
auf jeden aber den habe ich auf kraske
tropf nehmen aber irgendwie das gefühl
dass die hid prox nicht so das gerecht
ist im 4 kids mit dem eisenstaedt
gegeben und er mir irgendwie so 23 mit
dem stein schwer trotzdem welche fast
kaputt gibt es irgendwas sowie klassen
auf gomez könnte in die kommentare
schreiben das weiß ich gar nicht
also gibt noch sieben leute legten noch
irgend was gescheites egal ob ein
bisschen paranoia
okay sei so macht man das okay gut
inventar sortiert diese saß das kann man
sich nur erlauben hall auf
einfach mal einen hier sind ski
kürbiskuchen für ein halbes herz
regeneration zu essen ok in den ecken
jetzt mal nicht so dass sonst wird er
noch zu früh so aufmerksam da nicht so
stark hat es wahrscheinlich schon längst
bemerkt allerdings läuft aber das ist
ihm geraten
ich habe einfach keine pfeile x com
christa und wo ist der hund ist der
größte titel meiner alten fehler der
krank okay das match soll windows server
optimieren so dass die letzte von 13
gewonnen alter was für eine kreisrunde
ja die gab ich hab natürlich auf galt
hier
okay wir schauen ob die spender und da
kann ich kann nicht reinschauen ja wo
der war okay leute wir schauen mal das
waren sechs minuten
ich weiß gar nicht mehr runter dran ja
ja okay also das war jetzt wirklich
krass das skill alter iphone dreierteam
kaputt gemacht ja okay leute setzen wir
in kurzen cut und wieder nach
so leute das war ja wohl mal eine krasse
runde zwei dreimal fast gestorben und am
ende doch noch gewonnen und noch ein
dreierteam kaputtgemacht jack russel
sache dieser session auf jeden fall aber
hey und lebt und top.de ja was ich sagen
wollte
in den nächsten tagen oder wochen da
habe ich noch kein genaues datum wird
ein event kommen und zwar werde ich mit
euch meinen abonnenten und zuschauern
zocken
ja wir werden alle uns gemeinsam
irgendwo treffen da mal ne runde zocken
und dazu brauche ich jetzt auch meinung
ich würde jetzt ganz gerne von euch
wissen welches spielmodus ihr mit mir
zocken wollt deswegen schreibt jetzt mal
eine kommentare welchen spielmodus ihr
spielen wollt mit mir bei diesem event
am besten sollte irgendwas sein was man
mit vielen leuten machen kann weil ich
denke mal das werden schon ein paar
zusammen kommen also sowas wie
montagsmaler den kosten nicht
montagsmaler sonnentor mapping oder so
was wie zu kleine runden ist er schlecht
auto zum schlafen herein was ihr euch
wünscht weil das video euch gefallen hat
dann lasst einen daumen nach oben das
tut mir leid dass mit der face com nicht
geklappt hat da ja wie gesagt mein
ränder programm spinnt gerade irgendwie
also amtlich premiere das ist irgendwie
das was damals sehr und deswegen würde
ich sagen macht's gut leute haut rein
und hat einen schönen tag zschau